it's one thing to criticize the media
for being biased but can we criticize
them for funding terror
ooh in this story from deseret utah
activist and capital right sold this
video to cnn
and nbc for 35 000
each this guy is charged
with storming the capital but he's a
leftist
so cnn gave him 35 grand providing
material support
to a guy who runs a group or who started
a group called insurgents usa
and was a freaking activist attending
blm and antifa protests
and then later denied being involved at
all sorry bro
but what i find funny is you can be uh
you can be a moderately liberal
individual you go as a journalist you go
and interview say the proud boys
and then the media says that proves
you're far right you can actually start
a leftist
insurgent organization go to blm rallies
go to antifa rallies
and then as soon as they report on the
negative things you did you say oh
actually i'm not involved i go oh okay
we'll take your word for it
there you go but more to the point
cnn claimed over and over and over again
what happened there was a terror attack
in the capital
yet they were the ones immediately after
it happened who provided 35
000 to one of these guys to the to who
was cheering it on
during one of those telling people as
a woman got shot in the whole melee that
he was a part of creating
and he was screaming like she's dead
she's dead and 35 000
i mean i i covered a lot of crazy
protest footage and i have some of the
most wildest footage i had news
organizations come to me
try to offer my stuff thirty five
thousand dollars is an absurd
number do you know what he sold yeah the
shooting video yeah it was the video of
the woman who lost her life so he had
the exclusive footage
and he got seventy thousand dollars for
it there's gotta be some kind of
criminal statute for this right
this this was this was uh evidence
obtained in the commission of a crime
this was an individual who was breaking
the law
and filming himself breaking the law and
cnn rushed at full speed not only to put
the guy on air they put him on there and
claimed he was an activist
they bought the footage from him yeah i
think usually if criminals are
profitable you just
you just kind of how much did they pay
my crime how much do they pay muhammad
atta for his like
in flight footage on 9 11. i'm joking
but they might have they would have done
that probably they would have paid for
that
i don't know i don't think so i think i
think the problem is that politics flows
one direction
that even though this guy is this is
being charged with
several crimes and he recently got new
charges added the news news outlets
don't care about you or me or anyone
who's listening to this show they don't
care
they know who their audience is and
they're they're they're feeding the
beast it's power man
operation paper clip they took a bunch
of nazi scientists that were doing what
we would have considered illegal
you know funding the enemy we literally
considered it illegal and then we just
waived their crimes and then made them
american citizens and
and paid them a bunch of money because
we'd like and they were doing and we all
know what that resulted in
you know that that mad scientist guy
puts his brain in the computer and then
takes over
uh shield and then hydra you know yeah
fallout new vegas no that's the winter
soldier captain america it makes me want
to just think for a second
trump he said the quiet part out loud
when he talked about us doing bad things
right biden just admits
that there is no universal liberalism
there is no universal human rights
there's only moral relativism
there's only profit power and the agenda
of those who have it
is is are we just finally acknowledging
that maybe this whole american story
that we built up this whole myth about
us being the good guys and doing the
right thing all the time it's just a
bunch of crap
but we've always known that like this is
the country where we
learn history as written by the victors
this is the country where
you are allowed to burn the american
flag for better or for worse
even back in the day when it was way
more controversial people would
try and cancel you over it you could
still do it you can't do that in china
in any capacity they'll just lock you
and weld your door like when you're home
well your door shut and then you die
so we look there there's that that
famous sketch
where the two guys was it hamish and
andy i think i'm not sure and they're
they're dressed like nazis and they're
like
our their symbol is the skull and
crossbones and the guy's like are we the
baddies
yeah like we have a skull and crossbones
they were america
does bad things but if you believe in
the world of superheroes who are perfect
and do no wrong
well then i gotta bri you know look i
got i got a comic book to sell you
because that's just not the real world
but good guys have flaws
the united states has serious flaws but
i think it's true that we
are and have been the good guys and
there have been a lot of really messed
up things america has done
and america has been exploited by a lot
of special interests and evil people
but for the most part we have we have
been this is one of the best countries
to have ever existed if not the best
in terms of civil rights for all people
the the rights
i'll tell you something real crazy man i
got i have to be careful when i go to
certain countries
people in this country they think it's
funny when i mention that i'm mixed race
but they don't understand that
that's that's very dangerous in a lot of
countries in the world
the views held about being mixed are
extremely
ethnocentric and it's like that's a bad
thing it's a bad thing
i uh i went to korea for instance and i
had a lot of people
say oh man wow yeah no you shouldn't
like that's that's like not okay
you know what i mean this country is
amazing we've not always been perfect
but we have moved towards bettering
everything as we've gone
you know moved forward and even today
it's it's
it's this country has done so well to
protect rights that we actually have a
problem of people
exploiting our desire to do good our
good will is being exploited by critical
race theorists who are trying to destroy
this country and who hate it it seems
like the age of decadence
like all this infighting like it makes
me think of the romans at the end of the
roman empire where
and has there ever been an empire that
wasn't ultimately invaded by
militant conquerors and then transfixed
you know changed has there ever been one
has there ever been an empire that
peacefully
became a new a new country 250 year well
yeah
well i don't know about peacefully but
yeah i don't either happens yeah i mean
either collapse in violent takeover
that's like the history of
all countries and empires that's just a
history of power dude
yeah so is that what we're destined for
is a chinese military takeover of this
country
fifth gen well yes but not military yes
fifth generational warfare i'm talking
about military teams
it doesn't need to be military it
doesn't have to be violent it doesn't
have to be bullets it doesn't have to be
bombs it's information it's data data's
the new oil
eased out of their house in the middle
of the night the chinese no censored
censored taken off line making sure you
can't use banks online
that's that that's one way that they can
sending misdemeanor offenders for
calling the cops by accident on the
wrong
guy to re-education camps is a sign of
victory
now i'm glad we sort of took debate here
on my sort of socratic asking this
question about his america
everything we remember it to me i think
what we're really observing here is that
it is one thing to be inside and to be
an american
in america is another thing to be on the
outside and not be an american vis-a-vis
american power
in the world right and the way that we
conduct ourselves overseas
and the way that we try to push our
universal liberalism moral rights
or human rights on everybody else and
over their objections
right at the same time as like
preserving all of our stuff at home and
saying this can't be corrupted in any
way
it presents a hypocrisy that people
resent for represent us around the world
there's no question about that but yo
do i want to live anywhere else where
i'm actually not the king no the only
place i want to live anywhere else other
than here
is some place where i'm actually the
sovereign that that's my next
yeah that's my next project well the
thing that makes america special is the
first and second amendment
something that is also in grave danger
from being taken away from us in one way
or another digitally online the
information communication highways are
taken over by special interests
and they're limiting people's speech the
second amendment also is in grave danger
as well there's already a lot of
limitations but
let's be honest here comparatively
around the world not a lot of people
have the first and second amendment
now as you said jack the
military-industrial complex has hijacked
american foreign policy
and the amount of human suffering and
has caused all around the world
oh boy there does there need to be a a
realization to this and an understanding
of this because the consequences are far
greater than what
a lot of naive people in the united
states could even understand
so you have to understand you have to
take these two nothing's perfect
we only could strive to be better by
understanding it and having an
honest discussion about it which we're
trying to do here we have to preserve
i'm sorry to interrupt your thoughts
i mean it's like you've got a neighbor
next door who's like at home
everything's beautiful in their house
and all the kids are successful and they
got all the money in the world and it's
totally free and
loving and kind inside their house and
then they're the biggest jerks you ever
met
in your neighborhood and they're killing
everybody who doesn't think the way that
they do
that is a dichotomy that is really hard
to square that is a
that is a contradiction our actions
collectively as a nation
represented on the world stage don't
necessarily jive up with our theories on
and our ideas of of who we are at home
this is why i think we got to
vehemently protect the constitution
because there could come a day when the
u.s government
is so hands-off and disregarded of the
constitution that they
allow extradition of american citizens
to china for what
talk in the chinese what they've already
done is allow the constitution to be
subordinated to terms of service
right corporate terms of service now
supersede the constitution
yeah i got a question though uh in
chicago
for the longest time growing up you
couldn't have guns basically period you
just couldn't have them
and then there was some big supreme
court ruling and then a bunch of these
you know chicago
democrats were freaking out because
supreme court was like yo you can't ban
people from having guns
so all of a sudden businesses started
putting signs all over their
door you know all over the stickers on
their doors no weapons allowed in this
business not until in this business
so now you can have a weapon but if
you're walking around with it you're not
gonna be able to go into any buildings
not legally i guess they could kick you
out i'm curious about like private roads
could it could someone who owns a toll
road private road say you can't bring
weapons on this road we'll kick you off
we'll ban you from using it just real
quick the reason i bring this up is
if we're moving in a direction where you
know our speech is now
subjected to terms of service and we
don't use the public space anymore
will there eventually be a time when
other elements that are protected by
the the constitution go private and then
we no longer have those rights
courts policing etc well it's happening
right now with the way that we talk to
each other
free speech in the same way the terms of
service are superseding the constitution
they're abridging your rights
first amendment rights and the
government seems very happy to allow
that to happen as a matter of fact don't
you think
that the folks on the left in power in
the united states government
they look to this censorship that is
taking place these new terms of service
that supersede the constitution
they're actually getting the work done
that they wish
that they could accomplish through the
government they are silencing their
political opposition
they silence the most powerful man in
the world
the president-american of the united
states they they banned him
while he was in office which is just
what the left
wish could happen so the the people who
are in power
who are guardians and defenders who have
taken
oaths to defend the constitution
gleefully
allow these corporations to run amok
yeah
and establish terms of service which
supersede the congress
let me say this real quick this is like
a visceral misnomer of
human rights to allow a corporation to
violate your rights
because you don't want to violate their
rights is like saying you're going to
allow
the chinese government to take you and
fly you to china to put you in a chinese
prison
because you're not going to violate
their right to do that we have a
government to protect
our rights that's why it's in place
my rights your rights our rights so
here's not not corporate rights those
aren't even people
that's not the supreme court says thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you